okay so valve change stickers and
apparently people are losing a lot of
money
oh oh bro okay so what on pixel's
talking about here for those who don't
know if you put a howling Dawn on a
Glock weasel in pause 3 It lines up
perfectly with the head and you can see
a lot of people have made this
investment unfortunately this is what it
looks like in CS2 oh that's rough one of
these stickers is really expensive wait
but is this also the case for the desert
Hydra for those who don't know people
discovered as soon as the desert Hydra
came out that if you put an iby power
sticker right in this position right
here the tongue would be coming out of
the mouth and it looks amazing it seems
like the only desert Hydra in existence
with an iby power Hollow is in position
four so this guy's safe the question is
whether it up other regular iby Powers
did it screw up the craft woo all right
homie safe yo us skin fiends are living
update to update